what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with invincible and this is
technically the prelude
to the viltromite war right how the war
kind of starts ramping up things like
that
so what we're going to do here is we're
largely going to skip over what mark is
doing with the exception of a couple
different things and we're mostly going
to focus on what's happening with omni
man
alan the alien the coalition of worlds
all that kind of stuff right so
the first thing we get here is basically
the origin of the viltrumites as it
truly exists as opposed to the kind of
little tidbits of information that we
got over the course of those
early issues and so one of the first
things that's basically hit on here
is that when it comes to the viltromat
race that initially they were just
a wildly powerful race that occupied a
world and that was basically it but
along the way
because they were so violent and because
they were looking to become the most
powerful race in existence or at least
more beyond what they already were
what they started doing was culling the
weakest of their race right as they say
a team is only as strong as its weakest
member and so because there were weak
individuals here they cast them out or
destroyed them well they really just
destroyed the minimum cast amount at all
but they just eradicated them completely
and then in turn
they started focusing on building their
race up and kind of allowing the
strongest individuals to rule
uh and that was basically it right so
there was really no weakness among the
wheelchair might race and so what you
ended up having along the way
was that they while they were just
overwhelming
just this overwhelming force that
suddenly their enemies
created a virus this is the funny thing
about that we're actually gonna learn
more about this here in a here a little
bit but a virus basically came into
existence called the scourge virus that
basically swept across the entirety of
the viltrumite race and only two things
happened
either those individuals who were
infected some of them succumbed to the
virus and basically died of it or for
others
they experienced weakness right they
kind of lost their invulnerability and
so in doing so
threats that would normally be something
they could easily overwhelm they were
destroyed by and so the result is that
over the course of this period of time
while it ravaged their race about 99.9
percent of all viltromites were
completely destroyed the irony about
this and the crazy thing is
despite all of that the viltrumide
empire endured and we'll actually find
out why because thrag or freddie mercury
as you guys like to call him was the guy
who basically pulled it off now one of
the crazy things about this this is
what's so nuts about the vulture mine
empire
what they did with the bodies of those
who died they actually turned them into
a ring around their own world and so
following that
a couple of things happen the first is
that the viltrumites basically
used their reputation as a means to
instill fear across the universe if
people
knew there were only 50 vulture mites
left at that point they would just be
like throw everything at them right just
be a war of attrition and eventually
they would just wear them down right it
might take a long long time to do
and countless people would die but at
the end of the day if the the universe
wanted to get rid of the vulture mites
that would be a sacrifice they would
have to be willing to make and so
using their reputation to basically kind
of go forward and say we're like we're a
super mighty race and then having one
member of the vulture might
show up to a different planet and then
conquered in the name of the vulture
mind empire
just the name of the empire itself
instilled enough fear that most races
basically bent to it at least most of
those races that were confronted
bent the knee to the velcromide empire
those who didn't were basically
eradicated or at least forced into
subservience the other thing
is the viltrumites actually started
experimenting with crossbreeding which
is to say
breeding with other races that were out
there and this is the reason why
earth is so important because what nolan
says is that humans are basically
perfectly compatible with filter mites
and that procreating with a human
would basically stand the best chance of
bringing vulture mites back up to where
they were before right kind of
increasing their ranks and returning
them back to quote unquote the glory
days of the empire and that's the one
secret about why it is that nolan was
truly on earth that he never told mark
that the planet was going to be turned
into a breeding camp right they were
literally going to continue their
campaign
of conquering the universe and while
doing that essentially have humans
procreate with the termites and then
produce children it's pretty twisted
and it's pretty sadistic and screwed up
but at the end of the day that was the
whole purpose of the empire now again
nolan's turned against the viltrumite so
that's the reason why he's really
spilling the beans to to alan alien
because he's trying to provide as much
information as possible
that can be used to bring down the
villager my rates and so the results of
this is he's like i need to talk to the
guy who runs a coalition of worlds now
from there you basically pick up with
with alan the alien arriving at home to
his girl and then like as soon as they
they kind of you know
they kind of start doing a little of the
damn thing
and then like nolan shows up and she
immediately freaks out and starts firing
on him with a giant cannon that she
keeps under the couch whenever her
husband's away but once it all settles
down
you basically have nolan who meets with
without now one of the things to know
is that nolan is basically wearing a
costume here and the whole reason for
that is because no one's supposed to
know he's there
if people just knew that nolan nolan you
know that a villager might was on the
planet they would freak
and it's one of the things that kind of
keep in mind here the leader of the
coalition of worlds we know he's a
filter might nobody else
does well i guess alan the alien does
but like almost nobody else does right
because the the disdain for the villager
might is so extreme
they would oust him now of course this
information is revealed to nolan and
nolan says fine if that's true i want
you to pull the two lock right i want
you to do this two lock pole in front of
me
and show that it's true basically means
pulling his beard out and of course you
know he's kind of you know alan's like
dude he did it man he's a filter might
it's good
chill don't make this poor sap pull his
beard out again
and so the result of this is that nolan
and alan are basically given a task
which is a really cool concept here the
coalition of worlds is really by all
standards of measurement at least in
comparison to the power and the strength
of the velcromine empire
running on a shoestring budget right i
mean they have a lot of sources that are
there but when it comes to just raw
power and strength they're not on the
same level as the villager might right
like allen is like the only well at
least was the only member
of the coalition of worlds that was on
the same level as the vulture might and
that took almost forever to get to that
point right it took a long time for him
to get to that point and so basically
what they've been sent on here
is a mission to travel the cosmos and to
find various people out there
that can help them and then really kind
of enlist in the aid of the coalition of
world so they can basically destroy the
filter mites right it's literally just
building up their resources building up
their forces is really all this is
now one of the things that happens here
is you basically have nolan who leads
allen to a guy by the name of the space
racer and there's a gun of the space
racer laying here this is a really cool
concept by robert kirkman the way this
works is that the space racer and nolan
fought previously and nolan defeated him
and then
essentially killed him the problem with
this is that the gun cannot be touched
there's a relationship between the space
racer and the gun and that if nolan were
to pick it up then basically it would
leave his
leave his control and go immediately to
the space racer and then basically
resurrect it more so than that the only
person who can fire the gun is the space
racer so it's exceedingly unique to him
and that's why it was just left here now
the idea is that because it's been so
long there's not really any major
concern to worry about
and the gun is what they were after in
the first place the problem is that as
soon as nolan touches it the gun takes
off to a pile of rubble and basically
resurrects the space racer now it's kind
of a funny thing because this gun
basically fires indestructible bullets
right like whatever it is that this gun
shoots will die it's just it's just one
of those things
and so obviously you want to use it when
it comes to the viltrumites the problem
with this is that the gun ends up firing
off and literally blowing a hole in an
asteroid which sets off a chain reaction
just has the asteroid belt all of them
start crashing into each other so of
course they end up escaping they
basically bail out of there and then
space racer follows them back to the
coalition of worlds once they make a
convincing enough case
that you know the space racers should
believe in them right because the
initial reaction of the space racer is
to kill nolan right like that's like his
first response is to like kill this guy
and they're like look man
well like i'm i'm sorry that we fought
before i'm sorry i did all the stuff
that i did before i didn't realize how
screwed up i was how wrong i was
at this moment right now i'm here to
basically make things right that's what
i want to do here
so come back to the coalition of worlds
i'm trying to do things right team up
with us
and we'll take out the rest of the
villager mics and so from there it's
just following from one location to the
next now one of the funny things that
happens is after this mission
that you have nolan who's basically
crashing and out in the aliens house for
a few months and like alan the alien and
his wife are just like banging right i
mean
and from what it seems like like when
they do the damn thing they do the damn
thing right like i mean it's it's
it's all noisy and stuff alan's just
like like keeping his ears covered as
best he can and i was like dude are we
or we're not keeping you up why aren't
we he's like no
it's one of those funny moments i really
hope they keep that in the show like i'm
so hoping they bring that in the show
but the next stop is basically showing
up on a kind of frozen world here this
place that basically houses these
well really aliens called the ragnar now
these are a big deal right the way that
nolan explains it like they are
vicious and they have to be careful and
when the viltrumites discovered that
race of monsters they sent a few teams
to try to destroy them
and basically the monsters destroyed the
vulture mites right and in fact conquest
was one of those not really destroyed
but like
you know that's that's how he lost his
arm in the first place and but the whole
thing behind this is
these things are capable of killing
villager mice the problem is that a
cannon's fired off and when that happens
like the whole thing melts right like
literally this whole entire place melts
and because of that uh all these things
start
thawing out right and so ultimately the
mission scruff right they're like we
gotta get out of here because if they
stay they're probably gonna die right so
while the things are still alive and
they're still
on that world it's really kirkman just
kind of being like okay like we can use
those for a future point in time and in
fact that's what the leader does right
like leaderly coalition that's what he
does he's like okay look so you know the
mission is not a total loss we know
where they are and so maybe we can just
like pick a whole bunch of them up and
then just like drop them off in front of
the vulture mites and let them be a
distraction
i'm not entirely sure but from there
again it's just kind of following along
all these different things right the
clax's plan is poisonous to vulture
might so they grab that they end up
going to the home world of battle bees
to try to find him to recruit him to the
cause of the viltrumide empire it's just
visiting all these different locations
and all these different places and so
what you end up doing is once it's all
kind of done and they've grabbed
whatever allies they could based on this
mission
you have this moment where nolan is
brought into a kind of room by the
leader
and has basically shown the reality of
what went on now the leader was the
first villager might to really defect
away from the vilture might empire more
so than that the scourge virus was not
created by some
enemy of the vulture mites i mean i
guess it was but it was basically
created by this guy
right like using his own his own
genealogy right his own genetic
signature he basically created the
scourge virus
and what he's been doing all this time
was actually amplifying it
improving it it's kind of a last-ditch
effort and saying like if this is this
what it really comes down to we'll use
this to annihilate what's left of the uh
of the the viltromites themselves now
kind of jumping back to earth here for a
second not really doing a whole lot here
but kind of jumping back to earth for a
second a couple of things
we know at the end of the last story
that conquest had been captured by cecil
and it was being held in like this great
big huge thing
this is just one of those examples of
cecil being an idiot right like you know
what
like a 400 ton chunk of metal sure
that'll keep a guy who's powerful enough
to
fly through space unaided hold his
breath for weeks at a time
you know and is one of the most powerful
beings in the history of the universe
like
sure that'll hold him oh no wait a
minute
no it won't and so this guy literally
just
breaks out of the mojave facility and
just flies back to the flies like
literally flies out of space and goes
back to the to the vulture might empire
there is the whole idea of like the
secret invasion if you guys remember
that the whole idea of like those little
squid looking things that kind of
happens a little bit and it's basically
defeated this is it's a minor plot point
if i'm being honest
i think kirkman wrapped it up here to
make way for the viltromite war um
there's not a whole lot that goes on
there right it's just a bit of a
conflict and people are ensnared and so
on but there is a massive development
that goes on here right
mark's spending time with adam eve and
as you guys know they've been touching
naughty bits and eve is just freaking
out because she's in the bathroom right
she's like leave me alone right as soon
as mark knocks on the door he's like
leave me alone
he's like okay and then you find out she
took a pregnancy test and eve is
preggers but like
it's kind of cool right i mean these are
these are a couple of things that are
sort of going on here again sort of
skimming over
what's happening on earth so we can get
back to the rest of the stuff uh but
nonetheless with regard to conquest
once he gets back to essentially the
base of operations of the vulture might
he comes into contact with
thrag now thrag is the guy who runs the
show of the viltromite race of course
you guys liked calling him freddie
mercury from that one video that we did
and i'm wholly on board with that
because if ever there were a guy who
looked like freddie mercury it's
basically this guy
and i'd love to believe he listens to
bohemian rhapsody i guarantee there's
gonna be freddie mercury memes in the
show as soon as thrack is introduced i
guarantee that's gonna happen people are
gonna be like freddie mercury
so that's where he went right like like
people are gonna start coming out with
all these crazy conspiracies and whatnot
but the whole thing behind thrag is this
guy
is powerful and as the leader of the
vulture might race you would kind of
expect him to be right that's one of the
things about the village right race that
we talked about
is it's not necessarily based on a a
kind of line of royalty it is to a
degree but it's really more akin to like
the spartan empire right the strongest
rules that particular group right rules
that race and if a situation were to
arise where like you have a guy who runs
the uh the victory right empire
and somebody else is stronger and they
rise to prominence and topple that guy
that's the nature of things right the
survival of the fittest and only the
strongest deserve to lead that's the
entire philosophy and so you basically
have have like conquest who begs for his
life right which just seeing how it was
that things went down between him and
mark
is an indication of how powerful thrag
is but like begging for his life
really apologizing for his carelessness
and saying look like you know i
like please spare me uh you know at the
end of the day like all i want to do is
serve in the in the glory of the vulture
white empire that kind of a thing right
ingratiating himself so on and so forth
which is kind of a sight to see for a
guy that's so honor bound and has been
around for so long
and so incredibly powerful and so
basically conquest is tash by thrag
to intercept nolan and alan the alien
and to kill them right so like do not
like
he literally says leave none alive
intercept that team destroy them
and that'll be it if you fail me you die
right that's just it's it's kind of
crazy right it's just
it's nuts it's a pretty intimidating
moment between these guys and so you do
get a kind of brief moment
where nolan and and alan alien show up
on the doorstep
of uh of mark and basically say like
you're needed right like you have to
join me now in reality
mark takes a moment away and just kind
of talks to eve about this whole thing
because he doesn't know exactly what to
do right he doesn't really know exactly
what to what to approach on this when
when eve asked him like are you scared
his response is
yes but not for what might happen to me
or even the outcome of the war
not mostly at least he says after
everything that's happened everything
i've done
how i've changed vulture my blood
courses through these veins
i'm worried about what this war will
bring out of me and what it could make
me become
that's the fear of mark the fear of mark
here is not dying
in the war with his dad you know
fighting in the vulture my war it's not
facing off against some
enemy and being just absolutely pummeled
and wrecked it's that it'll turn him
into a very dark and evil person he'll
end up becoming like his father or at
least the way his father was
that's his biggest fear but we'll have
to get into the vulture my war to find
out what actually happens with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace